each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so without anything further we will get
on with a plenary session and it's my
great pleasure to introduce Geoffrey Fox
and invite him to the stage for
distributed and parallel programming
environments in their performance thank
you very much for inviting me so this
talk will be about the plumbing of e
science and I'd like to thank people in
my research group and collaborators and
also especially a Microsoft about
helping us technically and funding us
and without any without these people
this would not happen so if you look at
the world today there are all sorts of
interesting claims that x and y are
marvelous and much better than previous
that previous things and we will find
that extra might look surprisingly
familiar but there are some changes
because we have various types of
hardware such as multi core which are
obviously very low latency we have nifty
clusters or high performance brown arm
systems and we have distributed systems
and these all have various trade offs
and then we're told to program these in
different ways even though we're
programming the same thing and these
include threads and MPI and MapReduce
and dryads and the dupe we're told to
use what mashups or workflows and if you
look at all of those above if you think
about them in the right way in most
cases they're all just exchanging
information usually with messages with
different formats and different
implementations and then in days gone by
we used to discuss a great length
various high-level programming languages
languages which were deemed to be
essential to make life easy but you
don't hear so much about them these days
and so here are some very old issues
Tony and I used to work on these about a
hundred years ago and that's how to do
parallelism and if you look at so key
issue for prism is what you have to
paralyze and whether that's what
features that has intelli the famous
analysis called RMS which is here the
types of things that might run on the
client or server of the future and
includes gaming and vision and financial
analytics and data mining and the
interesting features of this analysis is
if you look at the bottom those are
things with scientific computing loves
and loves and knows about because they
just standard linear algebra and related
types of algorithms so it's not so
different and one point we will note is
that MPI is in disgrace and not
generally the night bites at certain
communities but it actually works quite
well and indeed if you look at as well
mention later MPI is a really good
MapReduce engine another useful pointer
to think about is what what is the
impact of clouds what is that overhead
and what are the what are the features
that really make these new programming
models interesting and so to investigate
all of this which is sort of how to
plumb a science my group is trying to
develop a suite of applications in
different languages and different
programming models and compare them on
various machines
this slide here looks at some of the
programming and some of the runtimes are
we looking at there's an MPI which
consists of long running processes
exchanging messages at rendezvous points
there is a system we like called CCR
from Microsoft widgets or threats you
can either use short running threads
which is how we actually usually use it
or it actually can use longer running
threats there is a dupe which consists
of processes whichever which rendezvous
points right right files and then read
files and we have a version of that
which get better efficiency does not
keeps long keeps the processes
long-running and this overlay then adds
dryad on the left which is we own you're
just getting some experience with that
it has similar features to Hadoop
although it also appears to have more
powerful communication mechanisms and I
also change CCR to note that they can
either use the rendezvous mechanism or
to have threads which you give birth to
then they do that thing and then they
die and you stop them again so here's a
very technical diagram and the main
point about this diagram is in days gone
by we used to talk about data parallel
when we were as in those days wouldn't
actually know much about data we always
thought that the data is living in the
memory of the computer and by data
parallelism we said that we take the
problem we divide up its memory it's an
the data that would live in memory we
put part of the data in each memory of a
distributed system and then we had the
owners computer all which allowed each
computer to process its memory so I see
a significant development is that we now
actually have data coming from data
sources and living on disks and we need
to generalize that concept of data
parallel and that is implicitly done in
a lot of the discussions we've had today
so if you look at what you're going to
then do when you try to analyze
data you will find the data comes from
some instrument goes the disks or files
or databases is run through some compute
state which is called mapping MapReduce
and then it either gets passed to
another computer ace or gets written to
disk or what have you and that's then
joined to another section component and
that's how you get work flow by joining
those two those components together so
if we look at this world it consists of
disks memories and computers interacting
with each other and here are two
examples we can start with first is
particle physics worthy this is data
parallel over the events taken that say
the LHC and then you would have to run
this through various filters so to
convert it from the raw data to some
processed data then you actually take
those events and form histograms and
then you hopefully find the Higgs
particle if you look at say a similar
problem we'll take as a contrast not
some different problem from bio
informatics of studying gene families
then the original data is sequences you
might want to align them you can
calculate distances between them
classism to find families and then you
visualize them or something so we will
look at these two examples the one on
the
left is the semantically data where the
Higgs boson so forming these histograms
is the sort of them one of the crown
jewels of particle physics and we need
to do that for data parallel mechanism
here to form these clusters of some gene
sequences that's also data parallel over
the sequences with a somewhat different
algorithm to identify those clusters so
here we can now start looking at these
MapReduce algorithm which is implemented
by the Hadoop software and Appetit this
the simplest example is actually the
identical problem to particle physics
the blur histogram in problem as a
standard aduke benchmark where each task
council number of occurrences of a
particular word and then the reduced
phase of course for both particle
physics in this world histogram just
takes all these data parallel tasks and
adds the number of occurrences of each
word in each task and then dry it has a
similar model with a rather more general
data flow so we're going to have lots of
performance graphs and in days gone by
we used to understand performance but
I'm not quite certain everybody knows
about performance these days and you
wanted to understand it from this you if
you know that performance you'll
understand this this slide if you don't
you want technically it defines what I
call overhead which I believe to be the
most precise way of measuring
performances and what the how well they
have wealth and present them and the
obvious point is made here that
overheads decrease in size as the ratio
of the fractional overheads decrease in
sizes say the ratio exists of load
imbalance or data communication
decreases compared to the amount of
computation
and we did lots of work in days gone by
calculating how overheads behaved and
there are also two types of speed ups
you want to look up look look at scale
speed up where we increase the problem
size proportional to the size of the
number of machines we have an ordinary
speed up where we keep the province eyes
fixed so here is the second problem the
gene sequencing with actually rather bad
clustering algorithm and we looked at
this in all sorts of algorithms a dupe
MPI Java threads and those are shown
here and also happy and we find a dupe
with some eyebrows factor of a thousand
slower can't even flood overhead is so
off and the reason is the factor of a
thousand slow is trivial it is because
for this type of data parallel algorithm
the humidity amount of information
communicated is small and therefore if
you write it the discus and use data
flow as a dupe does you will find huge
overheads so we invented a very trivial
which I'm sure other people have
enhancements to a dupe which we call
here CTO MapReduce cgl the name of my
lab and all that does is it does not
have short running processes it keeps
the processes running between the
iterations of the map phase so that you
do not have to keep writing rewriting
the data to disk for the next space and
you will find that this thing here is
actually the comes along here
and eventually catches up with mpi in
terms of performance and the reason it
doesn't do as well as MPI for very small
data sizes here we have the data set
sorry across the bottom here and here's
the performance and in the execution
time and this is the usual result when
you have a small data sets obviously
overhead things that contribute to
overhead are more important
and systems like a dupe or MapReduce
using communication mechanisms and take
milliseconds not microseconds and
therefore MPI will win for very small
data sets but for large data sets it's
fine to take milliseconds of a
communication and you will find these
more flexible environments to work quite
well so that just explains cgo MapReduce
put them and it just says we actually
have this rather mature
publish-subscribe system which
effectively maintains queues in the sky
or in the cloud and this just uses that
to stream the data between different
stages now only a hand if we look at
particle physics data analysis and
compare a dupe with CGI MapReduce
they're almost identical and the reason
is clear for particle physics and that
type of application were dominated by
reading the data from disk and these
overheads we discussed are not relevant
and further apart the histogram process
is not iterative clustering is iterative
in with making histograms we just
process the data run it through a single
filter and so systems like a do but
MapReduce a very effective and actually
MapReduce does la see data analysis
excellent
and this just shows some of the more
data both implementations on this
particle physics que son scale well as
you scale and they don't give you it
these are not perfectly scaling and
depends on the less you have depends how
many disks you have of our particular
implementation we got speed ups of
around 4 on up to 88 notes so the way
now we can just finish this particular
set section of the talk and it just
compares the Duke with on the various
standard applications of the Hadoop type
benchmark and we will add dry after this
when we when we have it implemented and
we will find us the the ones that the
cgl MapReduce which does not write the
disk unnecessarily clearly outperforms
our Duke but not by a factor of a
thousand this time because we're not
iterating if you read if you read dry
earth documentation it says it will
support streaming and so it should
actually be competitive with CGI
MapReduce here's the distributed grep
doing a graph over lots of ifs against
the size of the data set in gigabytes
gain they're pretty similar alright so
that's the end so we deduce from that
but things are reasonable if you take a
problem for which these are paradigms
are suitable you get good performance
there is an interesting intermediate
between MapReduce and say MPI which has
some of the overheads of of MapReduce
namely using millisecond style overheads
but does not have the over does not have
such a high overhead in terms of using
disks so extensively
so as a I'm not going to stress this
discussion of clouds so we did try to
measure MPI as other people are some
clouds and we sort of discovered the
results we see here we see the usual yes
expectation the game this is on this
clustering algorithm when we have a lot
of data the performance of the
clustering algorithm on clouds which is
this some red line while this is on but
with virtual machines to be more precise
versus the native MPI then there's a
clear overhead and that overhead
disappears as you increase the size of
the problem if you try to study in more
detail by increasing the size of them of
the MPI overhead artificially by just
calling MPI a hundred times just to make
it important you will find that one
interesting feature which is I don't
fully understand but it's probably not
too surprising that the the the overhead
due to over mbi has has huge
fluctuations which if you measure it the
mean is this green line the maximum of
the red line of the minimum is the
purple line and so that's just the these
clouds have all sorts of interesting new
performance wrinkles that need to be
borne in mind so I eucalyptus does not
have such a large overhead but we do not
know but they should be similar because
it's using the same virtual machines and
that's presumably Jews of the particular
hardware setup it has so we deduce from
this we need to do some controlled
experiments on a single piece of
hardware where we can do the raw
measurements and the vm based
measurements with a different vm
approaches and try to measure the
overhead scientifically we have not done
that yet
so I'm not going to make a little point
here about the overheads we saw in the
first few graphs and you know we talked
about so that things like mapreduce
leduc support data flow if you look at
classical parallel computing it does not
for ya many algorithms do data flow we
do that's what I call Delta fluff then
it does not send all the data it just
sends it since the change and that's a
one of the reasons you saw much better
form performance from the
implementations which had long running
processes compared to the
implementations which had the process
did its thing and then reinstated the
process so Tony and I some not our first
paper well one of our papers was a
matrix multiplication and matrix
multiplication does have one useful
feature it actually has it's actually
quite okay for data flow because the
computation is actually larger goes like
going into the 1.5 whether where the
communication goes like n so whereas for
pdes as a catastrophe where the
communication is a small power of the
computation for matrix multiplication we
should get reasonable answers
so so I was so this says is what we
observed is hardly surprising so here is
matrix multiplication and so here
there's an intuitive algorithm and
actually a dupe is doing fine it's very
competitive with CTR MapReduce we will
add NPI to this we expect mpit from
other measurements to be similar to the
cgl marriages so that says we can
understand where these systems will work
quite well we just have to think about
the amount of communication versus the
amount of calculations do it like that
so these will all done with 40 40 cause
okay so I just you know I come back to
the point that parallel computing
concluded that NP I was hopeless but
actually a dupe and dry at our Empire I
sort of they are they have a higher
level control language but their runtime
is very similar that key construct such
as reduce is just as well done as Empire
MPI produces a very elegant concept and
you could say that the model that a dupe
MapReduce has is to have a library
filters the things that you can do your
maps for your reductions and that
actually is in my opinion one of the
best ways to do parallel computing you
just have a library of parallel
algorithms you just pick the one and
then you have some high-level workflow
or some other type of functional
language or what you like to control how
those modules are used and so I already
mentioned this I think is useful to
generalize what we used to do in the old
days the owner computes rule which says
that the data is stored in the memory of
a certain computer that computer
calculates it or simulates it to the
disk memory map bra which the CPU are I
mean here we can have
Jim Gray's idea of moving the computing
to the desk and then that disk uses the
computer's memory and that computer
filters that disk eight so I would say
that's an interesting development of
these new paradigms they've generalized
the owner computer off to what I have
tentatively call the disk memory natural
there's probably a better name for but
the essential idea is we never in days
gone by we never thought of weather day
they came from we just thought of it
living in memory now the crib if you
listen to all these talks here and the
talks will soon come they don't think
that way correctly because the data
lives in databases or on instruments so
you can see that a dupe and dryad have
added this new critical concept that did
not exist in previous parallel
programming models we should not think
of the data living in memory the data
starts on disk so that insight i think
is reasonably important all right so now
we have an you now go and look at some
detailed multi-core results and they are
four will do this for this a couple of
algorithms that the one I was present
most results on as a clustering
algorithm which I changed up over the
last few months because I found a
brilliant paper written by some German
scientists who are hard by Google and
they have developed a very powerful
variant of the clustering algorithm I'm
familiar with and it's a we will use
that in a talk like this I cannot tell
you about the wide deterministic
annealing is a very good idea for people
who are physicist it corresponds to
taking the Gibbs distribution which is
the distribution of states at a certain
temperature and you actually do the
integral analytically of the Gibbs
distribution of the objective function
and that's why it's deterministic you do
not do it by Monte Carlo as you doin
simulated annealing so you get the
advantage of simulated annealing with a
much faster algorithm
it is there is no Monte Carlo in the
cities and methods and all right so we
will and the interesting feature of
these this particular clustering
algorithm is it does not need vectors at
just these distances and there are many
areas where it's not so easy to find
vectors or else a rather peculiar like
gene sequences where the vectors are
vectors of features proteins and amino
amino acids and that's not so obvious
but such vectors mean all right so so
this anyway this classroom I already
showed you some results of it so it
here's some various results these are
also done something which George
mentioned i think it was yesterday that
it's very hard to visualize high
dimensional spaces so i don't know that
I agree with that I mean there is an
algorithm called MDS multi-dimension
multi-dimensional scaling which
corresponds a two to one essentially
doing a chi-squared fit of the distances
between high dimensional points and
distances and whatever target to mention
you want and chi-squared fitting is well
understood and as far as i can see it
gives good answer so all of these are
and why are these algorithms interesting
these are actually blue waters style
algorithms in principle you can want to
run these or these are all order N
squared algorithms and can be a million
and so these could well be and so this
is another example of interesting
feature of cows these are algorithms we
want to use them they would want a very
large and thread thread or MPI engine to
make them run properly because they were
they can use they do paralyzed well and
they're very computationally intense
and here's another example where we
clustered some that the previous classes
were in about a thousand dimensional
space of sequences this is on about a
twenty dimensional space space of
patient record data and you see lots of
nice clusters and the visualization
shows them so let's sir so in order to
implement these we have used both MPI
and this threading system called CCF
when I started looking at ccr I'm sure I
was sure it was going to be useless and
I was pleasantly surprised that it has
remarkably good performance and so that
search so and the other interesting
feature compared to MPI it has seven
primitives one of MPI's weaknesses it
has several hundred primitives now of
course it doesn't do everything that MPI
does but it is a lot easier to think of
seven primitives becoming standard in in
the field than 400 primitives so and
those primitives are various obvious
things like writing to ports reading
from ports and reading from reading
multiple items from ports and reading
from multiple ports so again Tony and I
used to discuss Ockham this is sort of
ockham be done in a more elegant more
powerful fashion so and this is a very
old steine from the first work idea of
attorney and all this does is it shows
the compares the performance of CCR with
the performance of various MPI
implementations on some actually by now
very old-fashioned multi-core systems
and ccr is not competitive with the very
best MPI nemesis but it does actually
outperform MPI ch2 if you just download
it from our God so here we have is the
MPI
exchange primitive down in ccr has a 20
micro second latency and as far as I can
see it has CCR is very competitive with
mpi for everything except possibly the
most intense the sensitives applications
sorry so this says everything we've done
and it was another point of CCR can also
be thought of as active message
alright so these results we just got so
this is so here's this parallel overhead
so an overhead of point one corresponds
to an efficiency of ninety percent these
are true speed ups are not scared
because this is a northern n squared
algorithm is not so easy to do scale
speed ups and so here as a couple of
relatively small patient databases 2000
and 4000 records and they are run on the
Barcelona computer using threading from
1 to 16 cores and the highest overhead
is twelve percent so it's a speed-up of
14.8 so on Friday we got our 24 core
dell intel machine delivered and so we
will just got the results this morning
of running that same code and so here's
the patient 4000 database data
application and now on the 24 cause the
overhead is sixteen percent and actually
this particular machine runs 25 percent
faster per core than the AMD machine so
this is pretty interesting you now
goodbye 24 core components and we're
going to get speed ups at 21 for even a
small relatively small application and
the larger application the speed us will
be higher and to get some more results
yesterday I got my four core laptop
which dell them michael dell an
advertiser simply computing and use the
speed up of the same application on the
four core system so this is not so
Don so precisely i did that this morning
during the during the lectures and I
noticed when I when I came in I didn't
have any power so I ran it first without
with only back arenas and it actually
carefully reduced its performance to
save my path and so the speed down
without battery is point seven eight but
with four cause so without power is
point seven eight before cause I gotta
speed up of essentially four and the
other interesting feature it's actually
the fastest of all the computers we have
per core it's about twenty percent
faster than this particular Intel chip
here so what the logician is we go we
have an enormous amount of power which
we can actually use both on our laptop
and on our local server here we have I
don't have time to go through this in
detail on a rather order code we did a
detailed set of analyses on the mixture
of MPI and ccr MPI is the results of
Andrew Lum stain it at Indiana
University whose MPI dotnet wraps the
Microsoft of MP Isis is done with
Microsoft cluster computing and you see
along the bottom here essentially all
possible ways you could think of a
mixing MPI and mixing processes and
threats and you will find MPI performs
as well as ECM and possibly better but
they all perform well and notice here's
ten percent overhead so these are on
eight core systems which until recently
we thought were quite good let's say now
we have 24 call but um then I realize we
had a mistake in this code which is
shown here when we went to the 16 core
systems we found that CCR on 16 cars
started getting sixty percent overhead
and then I looked at the code and
realized the problem was that um we had
not paralyzed part of the code so that's
one problem with a shared memory model
you can actually forget the paralyzed
part of the code because it still works
and it runs sequentially and so I will
not go through these and Dida so we
learned a lesson here about see about
shared memory programming you have to be
careful but on these results here if you
look at them will show that apart from
that problem which is our codes problem
we these actually scale up to eight
nodes each of 16 course and we get good
speed ups so I'm expecting on these
applications to get over heads of around
ten percent so hit in the last few
minutes we will discuss some little
lessons so we learned that MPI and ccr
get could speed up MPI is trivially easy
to express reduces just here it is this
is copied from my code since then that's
how we do a reduce operation online it's
actually pretty difficult reading it
actually takes a little longer and
they're not so obvious primitives to do
reduction with threats because yeah it's
not so trivial and I think there ought
to be some interesting research as to
how to do reduction operations with
threads if you look at the hard part of
MPI the ones that caused all the
difficulty and program it comes from
when you use send and receive if that's
the or the that's when you get you
really have to think more carefully
about the algorithms but that of course
is not so easy to do in these new
programming models they've actually
captured the part that was not so
difficult to do and I have one I mean it
there was one little comment on Windows
Windows does have runtime fluctuations
so if we look at the if you look at
running power threads in in parallel you
will find in Linux sorry this is so
here's windows you have five percent
fluctuations in runtime just due to
Windows interfering with the runs if you
go the Linux it's about a factor of 10
smaller but five percent is not a
problem and we do not see that scaling
up to anyway so we still do not have
problems on on eight course I'm sorry an
eighth note on us on our clusters and I
already mentioned that this memory maps
rule and this is my final slide so these
laptops when you're on CC are you can I
did most of those runs on the those
pictures they were produced actually on
this laptop running at the same time I
was doing email and other things so
there is no problem on this floor core
in my I expect them running off three
core simulations and do it using one car
to do do all your standard stuff so our
laptops are going to come a very
powerful component of our environment
and threatening is going to have a lot
of advantages because we can is very
easy to make threading down to write the
code so that the number of threads used
is dynamic so that after you want to do
something like work which will cause
more cause you will you would reduce the
number of threads you assigned to your
simulation and
the cloud will as I mentioned is
obviously going to be an important
components that we can upload the
process which is too large for the
laptops into the cloud but for these for
the types of data analysis i was looking
at we're going to need this cloud to be
able to launch large MPI jobs which are
presumably not going to be virtual
machine-based at least not in the near
future because we don't seem to know how
to make them run efficiently so I would
say this is a pretty exciting time we
have these new models they fit their
performance seems to fit well with what
to expect and the technology is changing
dramatically and I think we will be able
to use these new technologies with
extremely high efficiency
thank you we do have some time for
questions and but we do ask that folks
go to the microphones for recording
purposes and we have a couple people
coming down to the mic David never asked
questions and so when you were doing the
studies on on the new machines
particularly did you also look at the
energy consumption of the systems so
that you could actually see whether or
not efficiency of total computation in
terms of consumed energy was also call
on friday but for the previous systems
did you also look at that no we did not
directly look at that I mean we would
presumably we are buying multi-core
systems precisely to try to get good
energy energy behavior because the other
one of course is soy cortex where
they're talking about massively parallel
systems yeah but sigh cortex doesn't run
Windows doesn't know or various other
interesting concept like C sharp so I
must I guess but you could say the
lessons of this work is that we can use
multi-core large numbers of cause with
high efficiency that should allow some
extremely energy-efficient architectures
and perhaps if somebody is thinking of a
question right now if I could keep the
conversation going ask the question
myself I'm very pleased to see that you
have a fork or machine here could you
talk a little bit about your point of
view versus the role of the cloud plus
the role of the client in distributing
in taking advantage of both the cloud
and the pliant given that you're going
to have so much power on both sides I'll
I I suddenly found it pretty useful to
be able to do my computations I was
sitting on your in my US air flight
running these calculations so that I see
it's fine to run I mean there are going
to be set all that algorithm debugging I
can do nicely on the on the laptop so I
think having powerful laptops is good
and these programs are run well but
obviously the large production runs will
be done
somewhere in the well by definition in
the cloud and we need to be able to
seamlessly move from the laptop to the
cloud including to the MPI engine or the
high performance computing engine that's
what's that's that's sort of obvious we
have to do that and we've her talks like
those the poor Watson which described
some ideas in this regard very good way
we thank you once again we appreciate it